Hi Dr. Kevin Connors here today with your members minute. Today we're going to talk about
gram negative bacteria. Why are we going to talk about that? Because we have a lot of
people struggling with Lyme disease. So Lyme disease is from a Borrelia bacteria. And
Borrelia bacteria are what are called gram negative bacteria. Part of the problem with
them, there's many that will discuss a little bit of videos here. Part of the problem with
them is that gram negative bacteria have in their cell membrane, a thing called a lipo
polysaccharide. So lipo polysaccharides are in the membrane of this gram negative bacteria.
So the membrane is what surrounds the entire organism. So that bacteria has these LPSs, these
lipo polysaccharides inside the membrane. So if you are successful killing them because
that's what everybody wants to do. They want to kill their Lyme disease. We got to kill
the Lyme Borrelia and the infections that go along with Lyme disease. And that's the goal.
Well the problem is when you kill a gram negative bacteria, these get liberated in your bloodstream.
So these things are now called endotoxins. They're literally particles of the bacteria wall
that now are liberated. And they're floating around in your bloodstream. And these things
are large enough to cause an immune reaction themselves. So it's not so much that you just
got to kill the bacteria. You also used to have to use some things that will key late the
Lyme polysaccharides. That's a huge mistake that people make when they're dealing with Lyme
disease. So even if they're able to kill the spirochetes, the Borrelia, the bacteria,
this has to do with H. Pylori too. We'll talk about the endotoxins that are generated can
cause more harm than the bacteria itself cost. So we're going to talk about how we deal
with that.